Rebecca katz of clean
soups. Welcome. Thank you.
I know the weather cleared a little,
but when we were planning this event,
we thought what a perfect time to
get together and talk about not only
comforting,
nourishing food,
but something that'll make you feel
your absolute best for the new year.
And I was speaking at length with Rebecca
before the event about how obsessed I
am with this book.
So do not hesitate to get your copy.
I can't stop making soup and I not
even really like a super person,
but tell us what's the idea behind
this magical vision of yours?
So today I think what we're gonna do is
I'm going to make one soup out of the
book.
It's the Moroccan carrot soup
with Chermoula and it's one of my,
it's, it's what I call from the
cashmere sweater soup collection.
I'm going to use this handy
Dandy Ferrari of blenders,
the Vitamix to whip in this
incredible amount of air.
And so we're gonna make this
soup and it has a special broth.
It's called the magic mineral broth,
which we will talk about.
And,
um,
and I'm just going to start so we can get
the soup cooking and then I'll go into
a little bit of like, um, more
about what the book is about.
So the big challenge for me today is
how well I'm going to be able to use the
stove top.
But anyone who's been to an event with
us now as it's not the most intuitive
cooked, but I feel like I have a lot of
technical support. We have your back. Yes.
So I'm, I think I'm good. So, um,
when I start making a soup,
the first thing that I do
is I add some fat to
the bottom of the pot.
And in this case I'm using all of whale
and I'm going to talk a lot about this
card that you have with the
acronym that is called Fass at ass,
which is bad acid salty.
Sweet.
And so just to give you an idea that
is like a little magic carpet that
transverses your taste buds a
carries the flavor back and forth.
So if you're eating food that doesn't
have any fat in it, it's kind of like,
Eh,
there's something that's not satiating
about it and you just kind of keep
wanting more and more and more. So
it used to be that fat was like, Eh,
but now we know that fat is really good.
Fat is really good for our brains,
but it's also the key to carrying flavors.
So I'm letting my pot get nice and hot
and I'm starting to see that my olive oil
is shimmering. So far,
so good, and said here,
I'm going to add the first ingredients,
which, which are some audience.
So when I make soup,
usually I'm starting with the
base of like onions, carrots,
and celery.
But this soup is just onions.
And the second thing that I do is
once the Iranians go into the pot,
I give them a generous pinch of salt.
Now salt is like a little scrubbing
bubble and it goes into the onions and it
pulls out the Iranians natural sweetness.
I mean,
we don't really think of
onions as being sweet,
but there's a lot of
liquid in here. Um, the,
a lot of sweet liquid
that's going to be released.
Now I'm going to turn this down.
And so every time I add what I call
like a new food to the pot or new,
it's like I call food, like my
little cast of characters. And, um,
every time I add something new to the pot,
I'm always going to add a pinch of salt.
And this is what we call layering.
And this is like,
so you're,
you want to constantly layer your flavors
because that's where you're going to
get what I call the maximum Yom. So, um,
I'm just letting this go for
a little bit just to get,
just to get a little kind of like golden
glow or golden hue on these onions,
because I'm in,
this can be a little bit,
if you don't let them get golden,
if you don't kind of let them get to
that translucent stage in cooking,
they can be a little sour.
So adding the salt in to help release
the sweetness and just letting them go a
bit is a, um, is a good thing.
So,
um,
you asked me why soups,
I like what's the deal,
what's the deal? Well, so
I've been a suit maker, my,
well since I was five and I was sitting
on my mother's yellow formica counter in
her like 1953 Youngstown kitchen,
which she still has with the old
coil electric stove, the whole bit.
But Anyway, um, uh,
I come from a family of
soup Sharmans and then,
um, when I was in culinary
school, I really, um,
I gravitated to soups and um,
I feel like soup is like
giving somebody a culinary hug.
You can get so many,
I mean there's nothing more nourishing
than a really good bowl of soup.
And there's a lot of the alchemy in making
soup and creativity and making soup.
And I think it's also of all of the,
the,
the culinary mediums,
like all the things that you can do,
saute grill,
be a saw ca or whatever.
Soup is the most forgiving
and it allows for creativity.
So,
um,
it's really good for people like to color
out of the lines which would be made.
Um,
and it's so I laugh because I like as a,
I create recipes and I have to write
everything. You know, I have to,
I'm getting everything dialed in. Like
all my measurements are dialed in and,
but really, oh, you're just throwing
stuff, just find stuff. Then. I mean,
so it's like I have to use my left
brain when I'm creating a book,
but when I am left to my own
devices, I am just like, you know,
um, hats off to the
wind. I'm this throwing,
but this is not your
average soup cookbook.
This is not just a regular soup cookbooks.
Yeah.
So you're right.
So I have,
I do a lot of work in the health and
wellness space and this is my fifth book
child.
And um,
and the cookbook that came before and all
the soup chapters in my previous books
were my favorite chapters to write.
And I really believe that soup is a
portal for really amazing nutrition.
And I don't mean nutrition that's like,
or a healthy food like hippy
gruely or you know, just like Eh,
meth. I mean, like, like really Yummy,
sustainable food.
And so through the book,
what I do is I give you sort of you the
keys to the Kingdom of a how to make
soup.
Like what do you need to have to do it
and what are the tricks of the trade,
what,
what are the tactics behind it and what
are all the nutrient dense things that
you can put in a soup to make you feel
like all your cells are sort of waking
up, right? So now I'm,
my onions are exactly where I
want them. They're like, see,
they're like Nitel Golden,
they're beautiful and golden.
So now I'm going to add
the star of this soup,
the carrots.
And so with those carrots I add another
generous pinch of salt and now I'm just
going to stir them up
and get them nice and coated.
And now here is where I'm going
to add like all my spices.
Now oftentimes when people make soup,
they think they never know
what to do with their spices.
Like when they're first starting,
it's like I'll throw them
in at the end or I've,
I've heard all different
variations on a theme.
Usually standing in like
the supermarket line.
I'm hearing people and I'm like, no,
you don't want to do that. So, um,
so here I've got this,
this is the base,
right?
And there's all this lovely fat and um,
everything is dancing in the pan.
This is where I'm going to put my spices.
Now full disclosure,
I am putting in saffron a pinch
of Red Chili pepper flakes,
cumin and coriander and some cinnamon.
Now when you look at the ingredient
list of a Rebecca Katz Book,
you go, really, God, it's like so long.
But when you realize that like I'm
usually using like five spices or three
spices and that takes up space.
But if you have your pantry set
up and you have your spices,
then really you're only dealing with
carrots and onions and olive oil.
I could completely testify.
I've been making soup side of this book
since the New Year and I have only had
to shop for ingredients one time.
Everything else was things that I had
on hand just was able to play with.
Yay,
really accessible and really delicious.
So one of the things that's really
interesting about the herbs and spices is
that we don't necessarily think of
spices as being like we think of them as
being flavorful,
but we don't necessarily think of
them as being like these antioxidant
powerhouses,
like,
like amazing spices can do amazing things
to our bodies and we don't necessarily
think that way. Um, but for example,
I have a teaspoon of cinnamon,
has more antioxidants than a half a
bowl of a half a cup of blueberries.
So super powerhouses,
so many phytochemicals
and things that you know,
can shift gene expression and
all sorts of things. So the here,
I mean we're making soup,
but we're also again adding some
incredible nutrient density.
So I am going to add,
right now I have a cup
of the magic mineral broth,
which you and I will truly magical,
truly magical, which, which we're
going to talk about in a minute.
But this is what,
um,
this is what I call
creating a flavor seal.
So I've got half a cup of Broth,
which I'm just using.
I'm just gonna let it boil and reduced
just a little bit before I sync the rest
of the broth in.
And what that does is it concentrates all
the flavor and it almost like seals it
up so that when I go and put the rest
of my broth then and I let it cook,
all those flavors are going
to kind of do their thing.
They're going to just permeate those
little carrots and onions and everything
else. And that's honestly,
that is the trick.
This part right here,
it's like Saute your
audience and good olive oil,
salt.
Put your spices in the main event,
put some more salt in,
do this little thing with half
a cup of liquid and you are sat.
So in the book I have a
template where I literally,
I do this template about how you,
you know the stages of which you,
what you,
how you put things in.
And it's like once you learned that you
can make any soup any way you want with
any vegetable. I mean we could be
working with any vegetable here.
Carrots are kind of easiest specially
because they're so easy and accessible and
warming and easy to chop.
And when I was in culinary school and
we were doing knife skills, oh my God,
we had to chop carrots.
I remember hauling back to my apartment
like five pound bags of carrots just to
practice. So, um,
now this is just where I want it.
So I'm going to put the rest of
my magic mineral broth in here.
And this is about
eight cups.
I'm going to probably use six
and just keep some just in case.
And this is a great way
to store, um, your broth in the freezer,
in these types of containers.
All right.
And now I just need to
find a lid. Ooh, Lid guys
coming. Lid coming. Great. Incoming.
Thank you. Thank you
Noah. Thank you. Okay,
so you ready to go over and tow yet the
main event? Talk about this broth. Okay.
CanNot get enough. All right, so,
so this broth has a little history.
So this is,
these are the ingredients
for the magic mineral broth.
And I created this broth 20 years ago and,
um, it took gallons, two
cycles around the earth.
Um,
and I,
it would like so specific just in terms
of all the ingredients and getting it
dialed in and it's Kinda has a cult
following now of which I am one newly,
I cannot get over it.
And it's the reason that it's so different
than a normal vegetable broth is that
I'm using it like normal things
that you would find in stock.
So carrots and celery and parsley and,
um,
but then I add like sweet potato,
like this is a Hana sweet potato.
It's like there's so many different
variations of sweet potatoes,
but this is a had a sweet potato or you
could use a white Japanese sweet potato,
or if you don't want to fuss,
you could just use any sweet potato.
But,
um,
but chef dd was kind enough to
get me the varietals here. So, um,
Garnett, a garnet sweet potato, um,
a white sweet potato because this
has a bit of a nuttier flavor to it.
And then just some red
skin potatoes and onion.
And then this is where
we kind of get funky.
I have some bay leaves and peppercorns,
eye of newt. No, just kidding.
And then just a little
and some garlic and onion.
And then this is um,
Combo.
So now I wouldn't use all of this,
but I would use about this much.
Now Kombu is usually used to make Dashi.
Um,
but here it adds a very
distinctive like Umami flavor.
But also this is so chockful
of trace minerals and,
and certain compounds of B vitamins
actually in this little strip.
So this is like nutrient
density to the, to the, to the,
to the, you know, whatever combo.
And it's a seaweed. So it's a kelp. Yeah.
So you can get an in any Asian market,
you can get it at whole foods.
It's got the shelf life of a hundred
years. I ordered some online. Yeah,
Amazon prime. I had
mine the next day. Yeah.
So very accessible and long shelf life.
So like,
so you're a magic mineral broth may occur.
So you,
this looks kind of intimidating,
right? A little bit. It's a lot.
At first when I got it all assembled, I
was like, okay, a big pot, luckily. Right?
So there are two ways you could go about
this. If you've got a big pot, right?
Um,
you can just do
one whole batch at once.
Okay.
Now I call this the chop and throw,
which was the best part. I mean,
once I cleaned everything, there's,
there's really no other work, right?
Because you know, here's the deal, right?
All of this skins on all of these,
right?
The mineral content in your
vegetables are right is right there.
Okay? So this isn't what I
call Glam Arama stock. I mean,
this is not like, you
know, a gorgeous Boone,
y'all or whatever.
I mean,
there's sediment that you will
get when you strain the stock,
and that's great for the kind of
soup making that we're doing, right?
Because it's adding more nutrient density
and it's not this clear concent may
that you're serving to the
queen of England or anything.
So we're okay about it.
It's like a rustic stock.
So literally it's like chop throw.
Really. It's like, um,
I think I even did a video where I was
like chopping and like throwing it in the
back or whatever. So,
and these are cut. Um,
these are, these are like the hugest
sweet potatoes in the land. I mean,
this is like, should
I go and dog? But, um,
so you could cut this smaller and again,
you're throwing it in all of this.
Now if you don't have a
huge stock pot, right? Um,
you could buy all your ingredients,
chop it all up,
take half,
put it in a zip top bag,
put it in your freezer and
make just a half a batch. Okay.
The other thing is if
you have an instant pot,
this cooks really fast in an instant pot
and it also is great in the slow cooker.
The thing about cooking it on
the stove is that you get this,
just checking on this. Hang on. See,
I'm becoming friends with this.
See, we got it at the time. Yeah.
So the thing about,
um,
the broth is that it's sort of like aroma
therapy because really my house smells
amazing. Every time I
make it, it's, it does.
I don't think it's the allspice berries
and that culmination of the allspice
berries and the w whatever,
but it is, it really,
it smells beautiful.
The ultimate winter candle and it's like,
so you're Starsen now like on the big
proponent of making this broth and in my
book there's a Venn Diagram and the
diagram is the middle is the magic mineral
broth,
right?
And of this broth you can
make five other really fun.
So he make
this once, right? Then you
can make a Thai coconut broth,
which is amazing. I pay her. Amazing.
Okay. Just Fyi. No, I showed
up today and was like,
let me tell you all the reasons
why I'm obsessed with your book.
We scheduled the event long ago
and I have become a complete diva.
She ever say she's a major.
She's,
she's like on the verge of becoming
the major magic mineral broth. I mean,
I'm going to get a sign, I'm
going to walk around. Right?
You didn't tell people about it. Maybe
you could get it from her. Right. So,
and you can make a bone broth out of it.
You can make a beautiful
pasture be foam broth,
you can make a chicken bone broth,
you can make a homemade veg, you know,
you can make it,
you can amp it up and make it into a big
immune boosting bone broth with burdoch
and ginger and Tumeric.
But once you've got it made in your,
in your freezer,
and I love freezing it in
these kinds of court. And look,
this is the best, the tape, right?
It's like everybody needs tape like
this to make sure that their broth is
marked. So it doesn't turn
into a science experiment.
But how long could you keep it in
the freezer? Two months. Oh No,
this is six months of this
guy to like a long shelf life.
And we're not lasted that long.
I've been using it, but right.
So it lasts a long time.
And if you're tight on freezer space,
you can let your broth cool.
And you can let your,
you can let it sit on the stove
over night and let it cool.
And because it doesn't
have any beef in it.
So or or animal protein so you can like
let it and you can deep can't it the
next day and you can
put it in zip top bags,
just get all that air out of
it and then just lie it flat.
Um, so that's if you have, if your
real estate challenged, right.
So the whole key is if you've
got broth in your freezer,
you have soup in 20 minutes.
That's the, that's the proposition.
And then you can make,
you know,
all of these different soups and then
when you make your soups and there's a
whole thing about storage, like once you
make your soup, what are you going to do?
Like back in the day I would make
soup and it would be like, oh my God,
I'm eating the same soup for five days
in a row. I couldn't be more bored.
I never want to eat the soup again.
Now when you make soup,
you take half of it and eat
and the other half you freeze.
And either this size or in pint size
containers and you mark it and you develop
a freezer inventory so that when you come
home at seven or eight or whenever you
have soup,
you
have like a variety pack in your freezer.
And based on how easy it is to make,
I mean,
I was able to make the broth and two
subs in an afternoon on a Sunday and have
done that then like three times and have
just had like eight or nine different
soups hanging around in the freezer.
You're exactly right. It's the,
the quickness of it. It tastes like
it's been simmering all day. Right.
But it's actually really quick process.
So I think that's where people, um,
we think of soup as being
this long simmering process.
Like when Mike Dad, I made soup
when she made chicken, you know,
her homemade chicken soup. I mean,
it was like a major production,
uh, because she was doing
it all at once and you know,
but it really doesn't have to be that way.
So I'm going to check,
I'm doing this like speed flash.
So can I ask a question?
Oh right.
If you are making a bone broth and
we're going to get ready to go here in a
minute. Um, if you are
making a bone broth,
you're the reason to let it simmer for
ever and ever and ever with some vinegar
in it is to pull all that
collagen out of the bonds.
Right?
But I'm going to give you a shortcut.
You can buy really high quality powdered
Collagen if you don't want to simmer,
you're brought that long and you
want to add that extra boost,
whether it's a bad stock or
it's a bone broth. If you don't,
if you know you don't want to go down
that road. But yeah, that's, it's, it's,
it's getting all that glycogen and college
and out of those bones and you know,
bum bras,
amazing guys.
If you ever need a reset broth is
really a good, a nice way to go.
More so than juicing really,
at least at this time of year for sure.
So you ready to blend? Yeah, let's see
it. Okay. Cashmere sweaters. Here we come.
All right.
So,
um,
hang on
the off the off. Ah, great. Okay.
So let's see if I can make it to
the blender without burning myself.
I May, I may, but let's see.
Okay. So normally I don't feel
my Vitamix this high, but, um,
since I'm front of the,
in front of a large group of people,
it sounds,
it's like a dramatic moment
and very cover your eyes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Wow.
Okay.
This is why I take a towel.
Are you sure you might get
spit art on your, okay,
so this is puts the cashmere
in the cashmere sweater soup.
Okay.
Now I'm going to put on my glasses so I
can see what I'm doing and I don't hurt
anybody.
I'm going to start on variable.
The [inaudible]
so far so good.
Everyone's saying,
oh
gosh, okay. And everybody
saved so far. Okay.
So
now
I've got soup,
but not quite right because one of the
most important things about soup is
what does it tastes like at the end?
How many people have made a recipe and
they get to the end and it's sort of like
[inaudible]. Yeah, I definitely right.
And there's that missing thing and
you're like, what is that missing thing?
What is it? What is it? What is it?
And I spent all this time and money
and whatever on my ingredients and it's
still kind of like,
so this is where I'm going to um,
have like three people to come up here
with Jenna and be my taste testers.
Who else wants to come?
Yeah, come on, come on up.
And we are going to,
okay,
we are going to do what
I call a fast check.
So we've got our fat in here.
Now we're going to talk about um,
how you finish off as soup. So, um,
what I am going to do first,
everybody gets a spoon.
Thank you
k.
Now
we've got to go from Yuck to yum,
right?
One is the worst.
I would never eat this.
10 is that involuntary spasm
of vocal delight where you go.
Hmm.
Right.
And I'm just going to see where we are.
Okay.
So I'm not going to say where we are,
but I'm going to have come in,
bring your spoons over.
This is like the magic trick.
This is like once you master this
and you have your little cards,
you will apply it to any cooking you do.
SNEAD's salts.
Yes,
yes,
yes. Oh my God. It needs
who's been studying their card?
No,
I actually got real depth to you.
Oh my God. See fast master. I'm not alone.
You're up bass master.
You know? Okay. So here's,
so let me explain what,
what you're tasting to everybody when
something is kind of hanging in the back,
right of the palate.
It's sort of like in Nowheresville,
right?
And what salt does is it moves
flavor from the back of the palate.
I care to the front here.
Right?
And because it's so bland,
right?
You can't taste any of the
flavors that are in there.
So we're going to put some salt in.
And the other reason to,
now everybody's walking around that
you're going to be walking around with
seesaw, that you're in your
bags and Lennon's right,
because the,
what the lemon will do is it will an
acid acts like a little Pixar animated
character that goes in and brings up,
makes a food brighter,
and also is going to bring up all those
spices that are in here that we can't
really taste.
Okay?
So I'm not even gonna ask for
numbers because I know. All right,
it was spot on completely
right. Yeah. Alright, so
I have a Meyer Lemon here,
which I brought from my tree,
so I'm going to give it now.
People are afraid of salt sometimes.
Don't be,
do not be afraid of sea salt with
its 80 plus minerals because again,
you're trying to make food taste good.
It's not like having a lot of
fake sodium in processed foods.
Whole foods are full of potassium
and potassium and sodium are likened.
Fred and ginger Rogers there, dance
partners, they go together. Okay,
so you're not going to,
you're not going to have a problem with
adding like a keep adding until you're
getting where you want to get.
All right,
so I know that I've got to add three.
Rebecca pinches here.
Okay.
And then I know I'm going to add,
okay.
Probably about
a two teaspoons of lemon juice.
Little bit more lemon juice.
See, it's like alchemy. It's
the question is how,
how are you making that decision for our
friends on the live stream? Yes. Okay.
How are you making that decision?
Because it's still wasn't bright enough
and I knew if I put in a little bit more
lemon juice, I get some more
spices coming up at the top.
All right,
now spoons again
and let's see if this has changed it.
We're almost,
we could be on this therapy
still needs more.
More lemon juice to it.
Yup.
Okay. This is a pot of soup.
Pseudo don't, you know,
and my broth was not seasoned, right?
So I'm dealing with no seasoning.
Okay.
More lemon juice.
And then I'm going to do one more
thing that I haven't talked about.
My grade B Maple Syrup, I
call it a drape of mape. Okay.
And I'm only going to use
like a little cap fall.
And what that does with the sweet we'll
do is even though the carrots are sweet
and there's like a sweet underneath in
the broth because of the sweet potatoes,
a suite can act not just as a,
um,
acting as a sweetener,
but to round out and balance a flavor.
Okay.
One more time.
And are those things necessarily on
your ingredient list or those are just
things we should have in our
arsenal there on my ingredients,
I always cue you to taste and that you
might want to add something else to it.
This is good. Yeah. Good. Yeah. Okay. Now,
one more taste because I'm
going to put a little topper.
So twist our arms.
Okay.
So don't go anywhere because I've
got to put the topper part on.
So we're going to put the Chermoula,
which is a Moroccan pesto and this like
a soup topper or a dollop as I call a
dollop of yum is like putting,
um,
a piece of jewelry on a black dress.
Did I get a, wow, did
I, do we hear a yama?
Yum. In voluntary delay.
Involuntary spasm of Vocal Delight,
right? The Chermoula, it's gotten
more acid and more lime in it.
So you all are going to taste this,
but you just saw,
what I really wanted you to experience
is this is what you take into your
kitchen,
right?
Just these little ingredients here
is going to make such a difference.
Nobody should be eating at a
five when you can eat at a 10.
And what you'll do is you will tinker
and I wanted you to have the little cards
and it's in the book to all
about fat acid, salty and sweet.
And you just just follow that,
you know,
and also the Chermoula had some olive
oil in it so that your mola was parsley,
mint.
So those really high bright notes and um,
a little bit of sea salt,
lemon juice and olive oil and that's it.
And some spice,
some cumin and Paprika.
But even if you were just
to put, um, just, uh,
and that by the way, the top or you
can use on fish, chicken, whatever.
It's like it's Shimmy Chimichurri
it's a Moroccan Chimichurri.
That's exactly what it
amazingly delicious. So that is,
that's what I have to share
with you today. You are now,
I hear by now w suit masters.
Thank you so much. Thank you.
Yeah. Does anybody have any questions?
We have just a couple more minutes.
Yes.
What should be the temp of the
broth when you're cooking? You know,
um,
room temp is fine and even if you've
just taken it out of the freezer and you
sort of defrosted it,
it's fine. I mean, again,
it's going to do what it's going to do it,
there's no hard and fast rules.
It might just take you longer to,
exactly. That's it. That's all.
It's can slow the cooking time down,
but room temperature ideal.
But if you're doing it on the fly,
go for it. Hard to mess it up,
right? Yeah. Tenure. How do you
know where to get good saffron? Ooh,
okay. So there are a couple
of places at home would,
there are lots of places online,
um,
at whole foods or is as uh,
they,
it's called Spice Lee.
And,
and also I use them as
a resource. Um, they,
what's great about them is they
make these small boxes of spices.
So you're not like buying cute and they,
they had beautiful saffron. Yeah,
because you want it, you don't,
and also the thing about saffron,
no more in your cooking than ever than
half a teaspoon or else you will get kind
of a must musky thing going.
Now you talk about the number of threads.
Yeah. And there's a sweet spot, right?
There's a sweet spot.
Don't pass,
go over tips on animal
protein based breaths. Hmm.
Yeah. And then you can turn it into,
oh, so once you've had your vet,
you know, you can do the magic
mineral broth one of two ways.
You can do it as a vegetable, vegetable
broth. And then if you decide,
hey,
I want to make a bone broth,
you can roast your bones,
put it in the magic mineral broth and
let it do its thing for a long time.
Or you can just start with roast,
you can do the whole thing, all
your vegetables, roast your bones,
put it in and let it go.
So either way,
the thing about starting as a vegetable
base is that it gives you a little bit
more flexibility in terms of what
you might use it for. But anyway,
it's fine. It's really easy to take it
from the magic mineral to one of the broth
variations.
Yeah.
Is the instapot actually good
for making bone broth? I,
um, I think it is just
fine. It really, you know,
because basically you're cooking under
pressure and those minerals are like
great. They're coming right out.
It's not, it's there, there, it's,
if we were talking about, no, it's, it's,
it's definitely,
you're not losing anything in the
instant pot because it's all like trapped
right in there. Right? Yeah. And
it's all trapped right in there. No,
it's perfectly fine. All
right. Well, thank you so much.
Thank you personally and on
behalf of of Google. Loved it.
Thank you so much.